Every year it's no different. The VMAs
are always some Masonic ritual right
there in your face with the checkered
floors and the over sexualized the LGBTQ
agenda. And this year was no different.
And I actually haven't seen any
Christian channels covering this yet.
And I guess pretty much because it's the
same old same all, right? But for those
who might be new to this stuff, who
might be waking up in the year 2025 and
all this is kind of new to them, I want
to show them. I want to show you how to
break free from this system of the
matrix of indoctrination, propaganda,
and satanic agenda that is coming
against the masses through programming.
They literally call this stuff
programming for a reason because it's
programming you. It's being broadcast.
This spell is being broadly cast over
humanity from Hollywood, the witch's
wand.
But I want to show you uh I I didn't
watch the VMAs obviously, but I did look
up was there any LGBTQ plus
representation in the 2025 MTV uh VMA
awards. Now, this year was different. I
don't know if they did this last year,
the year before, or what, but
MTV VMA Awards used to be on MTV. This
year it was on CBS. I guess maybe it was
airing simultaneously on both, but you
know, MTV can usually get away with a
little bit more because it's a it's a
cable channel, so they were a little
more risky with some of the things that
they put on television. But CBS, that's
like regular broadcast television. And I
can't believe as I was skimming through
each of the little performances how just
blatantly sexual it was. Like the stuff
that they show on the VMA awards in
front of millions of people in in the
audience and in their homes watching
this, they show more on stage than than
the strip clubs used to. like the
burlesque shows and all that stuff. They
covered more than what happens now. And
it's just really mind-blowing. If you
can't see that we're living in Sodom and
Gomorrah right now, the days of Noah,
the days of Lot, you know, Jesus talked
about what will be the signs of his
coming will be. He said it'll be like
the days of Noah and of Lot. So the days
of Noah, it said there was only evil
continually in the in the hearts of men,
in the in their minds. You know, their
their thoughts were only evil
continually. Now, think about that. That
sounds like, whoa, that's way out there.
Like, there's there's still good people
in the world and all that stuff, but
think about it. If you are entertaining
your mind with things that are over
sexualized or uh full of murder, think
of every video game that's out there.
how every video game is over sexualized
murder and demonic occult. I mean,
there's all these occult symbols and
stuff everywhere. So, I did a
presentation on gaming. 23 of America
play video games on a regular basis. So,
that's a lot of the population who are
playing these violent, over sexualized,
occult games. That's going into your
mind. People are watching MTV. They're
listening to the music. They're watching
K-pop Demon Hunter and all these things.
The thoughts of their mind are only evil
continually. Are we in the days of Noah?
I believe we are. What about Sodom
Gomorrah? What was Sodom and Gomorrah's
sin? Everybody recognizes them for one
obvious sin because we even still use
that word today, sodomy. They were
turning their lust one to another and
all this stuff, right? men with men and
and women with women. That was like what
they were known for. Now that's being
pushed like crazy. Now I keep hearing
people say, "Oh, you know, Trump's going
to shut down Pride and Woke and all this
stuff." Man, it it's all an agenda. Like
I I hope you guys see by now that left
and right, red and blue, are both two
wings of the same bird. I mean, don't
fall for this Jesuit theater. It's all
bogus. Don't fall into the trap of, "Oh,
no. We got a good one now." Like, he's
he's changing everything. He's getting
rid of all that woke stuff. And man,
he's doing some great things. Look, if
if all you can do is bring normal back,
that's really not doing anything
positive. It's not. It's order out of
chaos. They have given us chaos so that
they can bring in a new world order.
Right? When when the world stage is set
and everybody's crying out something
needs to happen, we need change because
we're we're in utter chaos. Then that's
when Satan appears as a cosmic Christ
and brings in a new world. Peace and
safety, right? The Bible says when he
says peace and safety, sudden
destruction will come upon them. All
right, let's get into this because I
just wanted to set the stage about the
time that we're living in. We're living
in the days of Sodom and Gomorrah, the
days of Noah and Lot. And it I asked,
"Was there any LGBTQ representation?" I
knew there was without even asking. But
it says, "Yes, there was a significant
LGBTQ representation at the 2025 MTV VMA
awards, including high-profile
performances, multiple winners, and red
carpet attendees. Key moments of LGBTQ
representation included Sabrina
Carpenters's performance. During the
performance of Tears, Carpenter showed
strong support for the trans community.
She was joined on stage by drag queens
from RuPaul's Drag Race and dancers from
the ballroom scene. They held signs with
messages like protect trans rights and
in trans we trust. What does that come
from? What is that? What normally does
that phrase say? In God we trust. I mean
to take in God we trust, remove God, and
to place trans is as blasphemous as you
can get. It's literally setting Satan
saying in Satan we trust. If you can't
see that, you're spiritually blind.
Baffomement is a trans being. Female on
top, male at the bottom. Baffomet
represents Satan. Satan's agenda is
trans LGBTQ. Everything perverted
sexually that God had created. They're
saying in Satan we trust. Literally
right there on the sign.
Conan Gays. I haven't even heard of
these people. Conan Gay's performance.
Gray incorporated LGBTQ themes into his
performance like Vodka Cranberry
performing a gay Romeo and Juliet with
actor Corey whoever. Uh Ariana Grande's
speech while accepting the award for
best pop video. Grande closed her speech
by saying thank you to my therapist and
gay people I love you. I was actually
blown away by that. Like that was her
whole thank you speech. I mean I don't
know she had a speech I guess but uh her
thank yous usually it's like oh I like
to thank my mom and my dad and thank you
God and uh thank you the team and the
producers. No, thank you my therapist
and thank you gay people. I love you.
Wow. I mean, it just seems so forced
already. I know that there's a lot of
people like Madonna and stuff who are
just so progay that they're like, "Look,
I'm going to put this in everything
because I'm she's just kind of a rebel
like that." But this type stuff like
this year, it just seemed really forced.
It was really a politically driven
propaganda and you you could see right
through it like there it wasn't even
hiding it anymore. Like this is
literally we're trying to brainwash the
masses. Ricky Martin, the gay artist was
honored with a uh with the Latin Icon
award. So he came out many years ago as
gay LGBTQ artists and allies. The event
saw a strong presence of LGBTQ
celebrities on the red carpet, including
DOAT. I didn't know she was Oh, well.
Okay, so this is LGBTQ artists and uh
allies, it says, right? Okay, so DOAT,
Young Blood, Rebecca Black, and Conan
Gray. So, there's a lot of
representation this year. This is LGBTQ
Nation where they're talking about in
trans we trust. So you Oh my goodness.
Just look at this scene. Um you see
right here though on the signs,
this is activism. You know, they're
they're out there with their picket
signs saying love each other.
Like these are good sign these are good
signs, right? Love each other. But
they're twisting what love is. Love
means um I have to support you in
wanting to
change your gender, like change your
biology through chemicals,
bi your biological makeup, mutating what
God has created you to be because of a
mental disorder. That's loving you. No,
that's not loving you. Loving you is
helping you through this. You would
never do this for an anorexic. You know,
if a an anorexic
woman, she's 90 pounds and she keeps
saying how fat she looks and yet she
sees her ribs and her hips are poking
out and she goes to a doctor and says,
"Hey doc, I need a lipos suction."
Would it be just for that doctor to
perform lipos suction on a woman that's
90 lbs? No. He'd be saying, "No, you are
not fat. you need to see a a
psychologist or something because this
is this is a mindset. This is not a
reality. But yet, Satan has twisted the
minds of the masses into thinking, "No,
if you're a man, if you're born a
biological man with a penis and you feel
like a woman, then that's not a mental
disorder, that's a reality, and we need
to make it a reality." The thing is is
if it's a reality, you don't have to
force it. You don't have to cut things
off and take hormones and things like
that to change who you are. There was
this movie, a documentary called What is
a woman? And it was like it's it's like
the easiest question to answer, right? I
mean, you can ask any kindergarten, they
can tell you what a woman is. He
actually went to uh Africa or a country
like that because he was being told
gender roles and all this stuff. That's
just a western social thing, you know?
It's like it it was forced on us. It's a
mentality or whatever, a tradition. So,
he went out to other countries and he
asked he said, "Uh, what is a woman?"
And they're like, "Oh, you know, a
person that can give birth like easy,
right?" And he said, "Can a can a man be
a woman?" And they're like, "Ah, no
way." It's just crazy. We live in
bizarro world where the simplest
question can't be answered because if
you answer the wrong way, you might be
blacklisted, lose your job, possibly go
to jail if you don't use the right
pronoun or something like that, right?
So, this is this is a crazy world we
live in. Sodom and Gomorrah 2.0 all the
way. And you know, the Bible talks about
that we're going to be reaching a day of
Babylon. He says, "Come out of Babylon."
What does Babylon mean? Babylon means
confusion.
And if you're confused about what gender
you are, that's Babylon. And so when you
see a sign that says love each other,
it's just the reality is is you're not
loving to
support somebody who wants to change
their biology because one day they are
going to regret that decision. When you
no longer have a member that you used to
have, you're going to regret that
decision. And no matter how uh depressed
and suicidal you thought you were, you
will be even more so when you've had an
irreversible surgery that cannot be
reversed. That's just the the the facts.
And so you see stuff in here like
goodbye. You know, goodbye, but it's BI.
So they're saying it's good to be by.
You can tell, right? This is like
obvious. This is not even hiding it
anymore that this is politically driven
propaganda brainwashing the masses. It
It's just crazy. Lady Gaga, she's
always, you know, pushing the agenda of
born this way and all that stuff. You
see this uh red filling up, right? This
is literally red fluid that is filling
up the walkway like a red carpet. If you
don't know what the red carpet
represents, this is a very good hint.
They're literally showing you what it
means as the red liquid, which I would
assume is blood, is filling the walkway.
So, when you saw a red carpet, you might
have just thought, "Oh, it's just like
fancy or whatever." No. This is telling
you exactly what that red carpet
represents.
Let's play this some more.
Uh, you can see phallic down there.
Everything's about phallic. Okay. So, up
here
in the back of the stage, it looks like
a a goat head or a bull's head or
something. You see the horns and the eye
sockets and everything. I think it's
actually two cherubs. What they like to
call cherabs, those babies with wings.
See, Satan's twisted everything. The
Bible talks about cherabs as uh giant
angels, powerful angels. But somewhere
down the the line through the
generations now, when we hear the word
cherabs, we think of little babies that
are playing harps and have wings and
stuff. But all of this is so this is
intentional. There's these aren't
accidents. Like, oh, I don't know why
those angels looked like a goat head.
No, that was purposeful.
And here she is. in this uh very tall
towering dress.
But I want to show you that
nothing that she does is original. All
of this, look at these movements she's
doing. Look at the tall dress. She's
actually possessed right now. The way
she's moving, that is not a dance.
There's nothing
talented about twitching around like
that. These are creas. If people who get
involved in yoga start getting into the
condalini, they will have these
uncontrollable twitches that are called
creas and um she's theatric making a
theatrical performance out of demonic
possession.
And so you'll see her twitching around
and stuff, but she's not the first one
to do this tall dress and twitch around
like that because remember I'm old
school. I grew up on Marilyn Manson.
And so he would often do these
big stilts with a dress on.
So I mean this is she literally ripped
Marilyn Manson off. You can see right
here. Look. And he's even got
uh a cross up here made up out of guns.
So I mean that's very Lady Gaga as well.
So there's that. And then in the
beautiful people music video, you'll see
the the twitching and everything.
The twitching going on in the tall
dress wearing stilts and everything. I
mean, literally the same demon that was
in Marilyn Manson or maybe still be in
Marilyn Manson has just went into Lady
Gaga. And so when I when I was like
listening to Marilyn Manson, it was it
was edgy. It was gothic, you know, it
was not mainstream. Of course, you know,
MTV played Beautiful People, but it
wasn't something that you would bop
around to while shopping at Walmart.
But now, this is what I've been trying
to tell people is that Satanism has gone
out of just the metal world. It's not
just rock and roll and metal and gothic
music and and all that stuff. Now it's
in pop music. Now it's in rap. Now it's
in hip-hop. Now it's in even country. I
mean, Taylor Swift was a country artist
and now she's a open witch. And of
course, she's more pop now. But if you
ever hear a Lady Gaga song, I mean, some
of them might be dark. But the ones that
you like catch while you're shopping
around at Walmart or something, they're
very pop. I mean, the imagery doesn't
even match. That's the craziest part.
The imagery doesn't match at all what
you're hearing. I mean, do you remember
Kiss? The band Kiss, they had all this
white makeup on and black leather and,
you know, black markings on their face
and everything. And literally the Jean
Simmons would flick his tongue around
and and blood would be all over his
chest. And then when you hear the songs,
uh, it's like I wanna rock and roll all
night or what was the one? And it's
like, I was made for loving you, baby.
And it's like the imagery doesn't even
match. It's so crazy. But it's all about
pushing Satanism into this pop thing.
Something that's catchy, something that
a lot of people can tap their foot to,
and then they're like, "Wow, let me see
the music video." And it's like, "Oh,
that's interesting." And it's just every
generation gets desensitized a little
bit more to this stuff. DOAT.
She, you know, has music video where
she's dressed up like a straightup
demon. But right here, this this imagery
is literally the Masonic checkered floor
with the staircase. Like, if it was just
checkers, you might could say, "Oh, it
was just, you know, some designer picked
it cuz they thought it looked cool." But
these stairs go to nothing. These stairs
have no purpose except for the symbolism
of Freemasonry. So, she's walking along
on the checkered floors, which is all
about duality, the black and white. Um,
light and darkness coming together,
having a balance of good and evil, like
the yinyang, right? That's duality. The
yin-yang symbol means that you want to
have a balance of good and evil. But
what does the Bible say? The Bible
doesn't say make sure you have equal
parts of evil as you do good. No, it
says to to flee from darkness
altogether, to not even have fellowship
with the unfruitful works of darkness.
Right? So, this whole idea of duality
and oh, as long as you have an equal
amount of good and evil, then then the
world's a good place. No, it's not. We
shouldn't have we should have never
known what evil was. That's why God was
trying to say, "Do not eat from this
tree because it's the knowledge of good
and evil." He didn't want us to know
about evil. He didn't want us to know
about death and murder and violence and
and thieving and all the things that are
the opposite of his commandments. He
didn't want us to know those things
because they bring pain, misery, and
ultimately death. But if you're not
familiar with this uh imagery here, you
know, a lot of people in here might know
all about this stuff and that but
there's there's people every day that
are waking up and and discovering new
things that that are going on behind the
scenes. Here's one picture of the
staircase, the checkered floor and the
staircase that's kind of windy, right?
Just like End Doat set right there.
Uh, here's another one.
You see the stairs that are winding and
going up to this star up there, which
I'm sure represents Lucifer
because these people are Luciferians. If
that's new to you, then you got a lot of
research to do. Look into Freemasonry.
Look into all these artists are in the
Freemasonry, the Illuminati, all that
stuff.
So remember this the the black and white
the checker the duality because it's
going to keep showing up but I want to
show a closer look at the um the
staircase.
So here's the staircase the winding
staircase on top of the checkered floor.
This is not an accident. This is not a
mistake. This was literally done
purposefully to show their allegiance to
who who they serve because their master,
Satan, has made them a god on earth,
rich and famous, and put them on stage
in front of millions of people. And so,
of course, they're going to
give thanks to their god. Lady Gaga's
song that she performed here was called
Abracadabra.
And so, Abracadabra is is witchcraft.
It's a spell. When you look up what is
the pagan origins of the phrase
abracadabra,
it says um that it goes back to while
many theories connect it to pagan,
Jewish,
and gnostic origins, none have
definitive documentation. The word first
appeared in the in the 2n century AD in
Roman medical poem where its use was
already linked to magical rituals to
cure fevers.
Um, so possible pagan connections.
Abberax. Let's see. This was a phrase
that was put on amulets and it says
Aramaic phrase. Many believe abracadabra
comes from the Aramaic phrase
abracadabra
which means I create as I speak. Now
what is that? Who did that? God did that
in the beginning. In the beginning God
spoke and it was. He said let there be
light and there was. So for anyone to
say abracadabra as I create as I speak
is to say that you are God which is the
new age religion that goes all the way
back to the garden of Eden. New age
started it's nothing new. New age
started with the serpent in the garden
when he told Eve eat this fruit your
eyes will be open and you will be as
God. You will not die. You you'll be as
God. You'll be all knowing and
enlightened. Right? And so as I create,
I speak. This is law of attraction,
manifestation. All of these celebrities
say this is what they practice. This is
actually how they rose to fame. Many of
them say, "I wrote myself a check for a
million dollars and I was speaking that
thing into existence." And a year later,
bam, I got that million dollars and I
manifested it. right here. What is the
occult origins of the phrase are debated
but are tied into tied to ancient
languages like Aramaic and Hebrew. Now
when you see this Aramaic and Hebrew
don't think like oh this is like God's
language then right? No this is talking
about the cabalist the cabala the people
that the Zionist the the people who rule
the world are these they're not even
they're not even Jewish. A lot of
people, you'll hear this term, um,
you'll hear people say, "Oh, the the
Jews rule the world. The Jew the Jews
run Hollywood and stuff. These white men
with little curly locks and and the
black hats, those are not Jewish people.
Those are not the Jews of the of
biblical times. These people that fly a
hexog on a flag, that is the occult. The
hexog is an occult symbol. It's one of
the most satanic symbols ever. Um, so
don't get that twisted. These are the
the cabala and it says, "I create as I
speak and all that stuff that we just
read about. Symbolic use the triangular
form was believed to funnel and drive
sickness out of the body with a letter
removed from each successive line until
only a a remove uh remained. I saw that
actually illustrated
and uh it's basically got the word
abracadabra and every and it spells it
underneath but it removes a letter and
it keeps removing a letter until it's a
triangle. And they're saying somehow
that was a magic spell to get rid of
fevers and disease. But we know that
only God and God's medicine that he's
created um herbs and things like that
can get rid of sickness and disease. If
you're doing a magic spell and that
disease is removed, then you have been
deceived and and Satan is making you
think that he is God. And so now you're
falling for these new age practices,
crystal healing and Reiki and all these
things and magic potions. But um that's
Satan's deceptive counterfeit of
miraculous healings because if he puts
an ailment on you like he did in the
book of Job, we know that Satan can make
boils appear all over Job, right? If he
can put that ailment on somebody, he can
remove that ailment and now you believe,
oh, I've been healed by this
supernatural being or this potion or
this crystal and now you put your faith
in that thing. And that's why so many
people are wrapped up in the new. Even
in the Christian world, self-professing
Christians are getting wrapped up in
yoga and crystal healing and having
their tarot read and astrology and raiki
healing and all that stuff because and
sage, burning sage. Oh my goodness. Like
Satan has deceived the entire world. The
Bible says the dragon is going to
deceive the entire world. Now, Cabala,
this is actually the chakras and all
that come from this stuff, too. This is
super occult tree of life is what they
call it. But, um, I'm going to show you
for one,
you can see the inverted pentagram when
you connect these lines here.
If you can see my mouse moving on that.
And it's got all these words and stuff
that,
you know, some of this stuff you would
think, oh, this looks Christian in some
way. But I'm going to show you. I'm
going to get back to that.
Buster Rhymes came out on stage with his
Masonic symbols all over his jacket. If
I can zoom in on that. You see the the
golden phoenix's
the
like what what we would probably
associate with like the British Empire.
this red shield. Red shield means wroth.
Rothchild means red shield. And it has
this golden lion standing up and these
crowns all over it. And when you look
into Freemasonry, that's what you're
going to see. These golden eagles with
the crown on top, the red crown. And
you'll see it on the Freemason jackets
and things like that.
33°ree.
Um, when you look into it, you'll find
that the lion often is represented with
Freemasonry. So, he's got that lion
that's standing up on his jacket. And
you'll see right here, you know, the
Masonic mentor right here, you have the
standing lion on the shield. So, Buster
Rhymes is showing his true colors here.
Right there on stage wearing red. Red
and black. Whenever you see red and
black together, that is super cult. This
is again, nothing is by accident. These
people don't just say, "Hey, you know
what? I think I'm going to wear this
today." They have people that dress
them. All of this is all theatrics. It's
all hair, wardrobe, makeup, production,
all that. Right? So, none of this is by
accident. Uh, Buster Rhymes doing the
the X across his shoulders, Freemasonry.
Um, you know, a lot of this oneeyed
symbolism stuff going on here. all these
pictures of one eye symbolism.
Hope you can see that there. So, he's
been showing his colors for a while.
Doing the the hand sign here.
Uh doing the, you know, be the shush to
be quiet symbol.
Um
oh man, this one's just blatantly
obvious. Like, believe me, this doesn't
happen by accident. Like, hey Bust, I
want to take a picture of you. You're
like, "Oh, cool. Let me let me pose and
put your eye right through your hands."
Okay. Like this. None of this is by
accident, guys. Um, so Mariah Carey, I
thought this was interesting. Mariah
Carey is old school. There was a lot of
old school people at this thing. There
was Ricky Martin. Mariah Carey. Bust the
rhymes. He's old school as well. And in
the back, you'll see these letters. It
says MI. Mimi is what she's going by
now. But what are these guys wearing
again? Black and white and gold. Black
and white, the duality again. But what
are they wearing on their faces? These
uh I can't remember what kind of mask
they call it. Masquerade masks. These
masquerade masks on their faces which go
back to these rituals. These Freemason
rituals. If you've ever seen Eyes Wide
Shut, I never recommend watching the
movie, but they showed a lot of that. um
the secret society, sexual initiations,
the rituals that they do. And
ironically, this mimi character that she
is, this is one of her personas. She's
got multiple personas just like Nicki
Minaj says that she's Roman, a little
boy inside her, an angry boy that lives
inside her named Roman. Um Eminem says
he's got Rainman in him. Beyonce says
she's got Sasha Fierce in her. All these
celebrities, these musicians, these
performers, these entertainers are
puppets for Satan, deceiving the world,
and they all have uh some they call it a
persona, but it's a demon inside them.
And she goes by Mimi, and she says that
Mimi is the one that's the sexual one
that comes out because she's more shy
and stuff, but Mimi, just like Sasha
Fierce, right? Beyonce said she's more
reserved and all these things, but Sasha
Fierce can sing loud and strong and do
all these dance moves that she could
never do. And Mimi, that is Mariah
Care's alter ego. And she's got all
these guys around her wearing these
masquerade masks, the black and white
duality. This is all showing you who
they serve, what they do, what the
initiations are, and this is what
they're into. They don't hide it. again.
Listen what she says here.
>> Like going in drag for Obsessed.
>> So, she's talking about how she went in
drag on one of her music videos called
Obsessed. Why is there so much push for
this? Why they, you know, this is, like
I saying, it's so it's almost forced.
Mariah Care's impact on the LGBTQ
community.
This is Mariahedia,
like Wikipedia for Mariah Carey. Notice
the butterfly symbol that she always
has, right? This is goes back to Monarch
MK Ultra uh butterfly symbolism. And you
see all these guys are wearing that
rainbow shirt. That's actually her
album. Yeah. Her iconic album, Rainbow.
And she every year contributes to the
LGBTQ community. and it encompasses her
activism, advocacy, and the deep
connection she shares with her LGBTQ
fans. So, what are we seeing? What is
the common thread we're seeing here?
Every performance has to include
sexuality,
homosexuality,
freem Freemasonry or the occult in some
way. Abracadabra, checkered floorboards,
masonic jacket, right? um the ritual of
the um eyes wide shut masquerade masks
and all that stuff. It's happening with
every performance. And here again, I've
never even heard of this guy. Somber, I
guess, is his name. And there he is with
the checkered floors. And you see right
here, it says black and white on the
because the photos are in black and
white. That's not an accident. That's
not like, no, come on, man. It's a photo
booth, black and white. They created
this thing. They didn't just pick it up
from some fair somewhere. They made the
sign and everything. And notice it's
always black, white, and red. Why? Why
the black and red all the time? It's all
symbolic of blood. Black and white
duality.
The checkered floor. He's coming out
from behind the curtain, the red
curtain. All of this is symbolic. This
guy's probably new upcoming artist. And
this is, you know, his coming out of uh
the rituals and everything. This was the
Conan Gray performance where he's
literally um they called it Romeo and
Juliet. To me, it looks like Sleeping
Beauty, but it's it's a guy. It's two
guys. It's again all the red, all the
red and black, black and white. You see
all the duality, the the blood ritual
stuff again.
black and white and red everywhere. But
this is the reason I kept this on here
was because I can't even show her
performance was so over sexualized with
men and women dancing around. Um the men
were literally worshiping her. There was
like six men in their underwear.
Literally, no joke. and they were uh
just like, you know, every every time
she'd walk by him, they'd fall to the
ground in adoration and worship for her.
She's wearing white. She's on the black
background. The whole duality thing
going on. The red is being c the red
lights are being cast onto the audience.
None of this is by accident. You don't
just have lighting guys say, "Oops, I
didn't mean to use red." No, it's all
all purposeful. But what I wanted to
point out was she's in this circle. This
is how easy it is to just do some
research on stuff. You know in wikah to
cast circle is to create a sacred
protected space by raising and sealing
energy forming a temporary boundary
between the mundane world and the spirit
realm which serves to focus spiritual
energy for ritual spellwork or
meditation and to safeguard the
practitioner from unwanted influence.
The process typically involves
visualizing and drawing a sphere of
energy and often includes elements like
cleansing with salt and water and
calling upon elemental spirits or
guardians. I'm going to show these a
little I'm going to go do a little
review here. We got the checkered floor,
the Masonic checkered floor with the
stairs. It's not an accident. We got
Lady Gaga singing Abracadabra again with
the black and red casting her spell.
Abracadabra. We got Buster of Rhymes
with the black and the red showing his
Masonic allegiance right there. We got
Mariah Carey with the black and white.
Uh I won't I won't stretch and say
that's a red background, but she's
showing the uh masquerade masks, the
black and white, the rituals that
happen. She also pushes the trans
movement, the the drag queen thing. We
got the black and white and red again
with this guy. We got the black and
white and red with this along with the
homosexual act. Got the black and white
and red with the casting circle again
casting the spell over the audience. And
this isn't just casting a spell on this
audience and the crowd, but also the
millions and millions of people that are
watching on MTV and now CBS. See, this
is what I'm getting at. MTV was more of
a a niche crowd. people that liked edgy
things, right? But CBS, fun for the
whole family, right? CBS used to show um
all these funny sitcoms that all the
family would sit around and watch and
now they're literally watching a
stripper performance casting a spell in
their living room. It's crazy. Ricky
Martin that we already read that he was
openly gay. Look, look again. black and
white duality everywhere and a lot of
the promiscu promiscuity
and him being gay. All of it's there
again the same routine. Ariana Grande um
she had that speech where she said I
want to thank my therapists and gay
people and I just want to show you
Ariana Grande is not innocent either
right here back in the day break free
back 11 years ago with 1.2 two billion
with a B billion views. And there she is
wearing the red bracelet, the red
thread.
Not only the red thread, but remember
that Cabala tree that we looked at that
I said was representative of um the tree
of life. They said the the Cabala tree
of life, but it had the chakras and
everything in it that is in this music
video as well. She going to show it. Oh,
look at that red thread. I'm going to
show you all this stuff. The red thread
is Cabala along with this tree of life.
She she puts it in their her spacecraft
and it powers it. This is pushing the
whole alien agenda.
Boom. What's going in there? That is the
Cabala tree of life. This is This is
witchcraft.
There it is. There's the symbol in
Ariana Grande's video.
Now, if I look up Cabala
Red Thread, check this out. Look at
that. Oh, very interesting.
Very, very interesting. The red thread
bracelet. I didn't even type the word
bracelet. Red thread. It could have been
like, I have no idea what you're talking
about. This is a very real thing.
Um, she knows exactly what she's
involved in. She came up with a song God
is a woman and all these things. She's
pushing the same agenda. We are living
in the last days where performances are
literally satanic rituals right there on
stage being beamed into millions of
people's homes on MTV simultaneously on
CBS so even grandma can watch. And what
is this doing to people? Televisions
that went from analog to digital so they
have more frames per second. There's no
telling what kind of subliminal messages
are being put in there. How many
blatantly
me the blatant messages that are like
picket signs and all this political
activism and the propaganda that's right
there in your face and all the subtle
symbols that people don't even realize
whether it's a hand sign or a red thread
or a cabala tree of life or a checkered
floor or just the black and white
imagery. The red and black and white. I
didn't even get into what the the red
carpet was all about, but look into the
red shoe club. These celebrities are
wearing red shoes, and it means
something. They're walking upon the
blood of sacrifices. That's why they
always roll out the red carpet for the
celebrities who are walking on the
blood. They're taking the I I can't say
the word because it'll be flagged, but
the uh the young blood, they're they're
taking it to keep their youth and
actually reverse their aging.
Do not idolize these people. Do not
listen to these people. Don't watch
these people. Don't support these people
in any kind of way. It is time for
Christians to start living like
Christians, to be set apart from this
world, to get rid of the trash and the
garbage. And I think it's interesting
that in this performance, Sabrina
Carpenter literally climbed out of a
sewer at the very beginning. She removed
a manhole and came out of a sewer.
There's some symbolicness with that, but
it's also just showing the literal filth
and garbage that she is putting out. So,
if you guys were inspired by this, if
you want to share this with people,
please do. Please click a thumbs up,
share this with your family and friends,
help us get this into the algorithm.
Help us spread the truth because the
masses are being deceived by the dragon
who's deceiving the entire world. How's
he doing it? Through media. We love you
guys. If you would like to support this
ministry, you can do so by going to
candidtruth.org. We got many ways to
give, including Vinmo, Zel, PayPal, and
we even have Patreon. If you'd like to
get a cool t-shirt, that really helps
our ministry as well. We get about $5
commission from each shirt that's sold.
And if you have supported us, we see
you. We love you guys. We can't get back
to all you guys. Some of some of it's
coming in the mail and letters, and we
cannot thank you enough because we
cannot do this without you. This is our
full-time job. full-time ministry and
it's thanks to supporters like you that
we can continue. We love you. We'll see
you next time.